[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm delighted you're here.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I'm happy to welcome you
to the annual Julia S. Phelps
Lecture in the Arts
and Humanities.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
the Radcliffe institute
promotes pioneering research
in multiple fields of
knowledge, and the creation
of art in many forms.
We foster cross-fertilization
between the academic
and the aesthetic,
because we believe deeply
that the arts and the sciences
have much to teach each other.
Even more, we know
that their integration
can encourage new ways
of thinking and seeing.
Because we are dedicated
to sharing with the public
the fruits of the advanced
study that we support,
we are pleased to welcome you to
a robust schedule of lectures,
conferences, and
exhibitions this spring.
You'll find a full
list of programming
for the current semester on
the brochures at your seats,
and on the Radcliffe website.
Today, we are here to enjoy
the annual Phelps Lecture
in honor of Julia S. Phelps.
Julia was a Radcliffe
College graduate,
who went on to become an
art historian, a curator,
and a devoted teacher.
Recent Phelps Lecturers have
included the writer, ZZ Packer,
the choreographer, Karole
Armitage, the filmmaker,
Frederick Wiseman,
and many more.
We are grateful to
Julia's family, friends,
and students for their
support in honor of Julia.
And I'm very pleased
to welcome here today
Julia's daughter, Susan
Napier, and her husband,
Stephen Coit, as
well as Susan Bush,
a loyal friend of
the Phelps Lecture.
Our Phelps Lecturer today
is Dr. Jeremy Eichler.
As a cultural historian
and a music critic,
Jeremy exemplifies
Radcliffe's commitment
to the integration of art
with other fields of study.
Jeremy holds a PhD in history
from Columbia University,
and he has taught at
Brandeis University.
His scholarship focuses on
music and public memory.
His critical essays have
appeared in many publications,
including the New Yorker,
the Nation, the New Republic,
Slate, and much more.
Currently, he serves as
the chief classical music
critic for the Boston Globe.
To our great delight, Jeremy
is also a current Radcliffe
Fellow.
While he is here
with us this year,
he is working on a book
about how music composed
after World War II
captured and shaped
collective memory
of epic events.
Historians' attention to
the topic of cultural memory
has grown in recent decades,
but it has focused mainly
on visual artifacts, like
paintings and statues that
memorialize important events.
Jeremy's work
turns our attention
to musical
commemorations, and asks
us to think about how the
past is venerated in sound.
He'll be speaking to us
about that project today.
But that is only
one of the projects
that Jeremy has underway.
He is also preparing
a book manuscript
about the composition and public
reception of a 1947 cantata
entitled, "A Survivor
from Warsaw,"
which was the first
major musical memorial
to the Holocaust.
That book grows out of
Jeremy's doctoral dissertation,
which was entitled "The
Emancipation of Memory--
Arnold Schoenberg
and the Creation
of a Survivor from Warsaw,"
which won the Salo and Jeanette
Baron Prize for the
best Columbia University
dissertation in Jewish studies
defended over the previous five
years.
It combines biographical
study of the composer
with a cultural and intellectual
history of classical music
in the wake of epic tragedy.
The Baron Prize Award Committee
praised Jeremy's dissertation
for its in-depth research, its
ambitious theoretical scope,
and its elegant prose.
That same elegance typifies
Jeremy's critical writings,
whether a review of
a single concerto
or an essay on the life
work of a major composer.
Two of Jeremy's commentaries,
one about a Beethoven sculpture
at Boston's MFA, and another
about the cultural amnesia
behind the sale of American
composer Charles Ives' home,
have won awards for
excellence in music writing.
Jeremy's critical essays
are lovely to read,
but they are much
more than ornaments.
They do important cultural work.
Another award-winning critic
and essayist, Daniel Mendelsohn,
distilled the task of a
critic down to this equation--
"knowledge plus taste
equals meaningful judgment."
He explained that
the key difference
between stating an
opinion and offering
a lucid, critical assessment
comes down, in large measure,
to expertise.
A commodity that may seem to be
under suspicion these days, but
is a quality crucial to
the advancement of both art
and knowledge.
We might all have
personal reactions,
positive or negative, to
a poem, to a painting,
or to a piece of music,
but we do not all
have deep knowledge of the
arts' cultural context,
of its historical origins, or
its political connotations.
Nor are we all fluent in
the grammar or vocabulary
of every artistic medium.
To understand the significance
of a particular chord,
or a brush stroke,
we must understand
the range of options
available to a composer,
or the array of techniques
that a painter had available.
For those insights, we
rely on good critics, who
do have that expert knowledge.
We all know the saying
that everyone's a critic,
but the truth is that
good critics, who
dedicate their training,
their expertise,
and their authoritative
judgment to deepening
the meaning of art, are rare.
Jeremy's contemporary criticism
and his historical scholarship
deepen each other, and they
both enrich the understanding
of his many audiences--
from students
in history classes to readers
of his insightful reviews.
In his hands, cultural
history and music criticism
become entryways to
better understanding
of the past and the present.
And that is why I am
so pleased to have
Jeremy here at Radcliffe
this year, and with us today.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Jeremy Eichler.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much to all
of you for being here today.
Thank you to Dean Liz Cohen
for that lovely and incredibly
generous introduction.
I also want to thank Judy
Vichniac, the guiding
light, I think we could say,
of the Radcliffe Fellowship.
I want to thank my fellow
Fellows, many of whom
are here today, who have
made the year so rewarding
on every level.
And I'd also like to thank
the Radcliffe staff, who
have made the year
possible on every level.
I'd also like to acknowledge
my intrepid quartet of research
partners, undergrads
at Harvard, who
have been doing such great
work helping me with my project
all year long.
Their names are Caroline Boyce,
Dominique Kim, Stefan Paul,
and Andy Troska.
And finally, our
special gratitude today
to the family of Julia
Phelps for making today's
lecture possible.
On June 19, 1947,
the New York Times
had some important
news to share.
America would be getting its
very first Holocaust monument.
The location was to be
on Manhattan's west side,
on Riverside Avenue
at 84th Street.
A few months later, on the
morning of October 19, 1947,
some 15,000 people gathered
in the drizzling rain
for the public dedication
of the future site.
By that point, a
sculptor had been chosen,
and a budget had been announced.
The officials who gathered
there that morning
to lay the cornerstone included
New York Mayor William O'Dwyer,
Senator Irving Ives, and
many foreign dignitaries,
whose speeches would be beamed
to Europe via shortwave radio.
Indeed, a heavy symbolism
hung over the ceremony.
Beneath the
cornerstone was placed
a dedicatory Hebrew scroll,
written by the chief rabbi
of Mandatory Palestine.
It's a little hard
to make out, but we
can see the scroll right there.
It would take its place next to
a sampling of soil transported
from the concentration
camp of Terezin,
and presented by the foreign
minister of Czechoslovakia.
100 survivors of
Buchenwald and Dachau
were there for the
occasion, looking on
as the Manhattan Borough
president compared
the future memorial to
the Statue of Liberty.
Albert Einstein couldn't
make it, but sent a message.
The text of the
cornerstone that they laid
that day reads as follows--
"This is the site for
the American memorial
to the heroes of the
Warsaw ghetto battle, April
to May 1943, and to the 6
million Jews of Europe martyred
in the cause of human liberty."
A New York Times editorial
conferred its own benediction,
stating, "May the monument
prove an eternal foundation
for the spread of goodwill
and understanding in our land,
and among all the
peoples of the earth."
As it happened, the
foundation turned out
to be far less eternal than the
Times editorial writers could
have possibly imagined.
One can still visit the
memorial's cornerstone today--
this image is out there today--
but you will find no
monument on this site.
It was never built. The
project quickly became
mired in controversies over the
aesthetic design, fundraising
difficulties, and
bureaucratic delays.
The site today remains haunted
by the memorial's absence.
After all the good intentions
and vaunted symbolism,
the space now stands
perhaps as a monument
to memory's fickleness,
its contingency,
its strange tendency
at times to court
the very forces of oblivion
that it seeks to resist.
The Holocaust has been
likened to an earthquake that
shattered all the instruments
intended to record it.
How, then, should an event like
this be commemorated in art?
This theme-- the limits
of representation--
is a well known one for the
first students of memory.
Primo Levi wrote about
the inadequacy of language
itself to describe the
horrors of camp life,
and about the problem of
rationality being asked
to serve as a guide
to the very places
where it had been suspended.
Claude Lanzmann, director
of the film, Shoah,
has gone as far as
calling attempts
to rationally, quote,
"understand," unquote,
the Holocaust an obscenity.
Against this backdrop in
the early post-war years,
as stone memorials went unbuilt,
we should perhaps not be
particularly surprised
that it was, in fact,
another art form--
music-- that came to the
fore as one of the earliest
mediums of commemoration.
If you think about it,
music has a rare power
to express strong emotion
without being delimited
by the kind of
semantic specificity
that is the province
of language alone.
It also is not limited
by the visual clarity
that we associate with,
for instance, photography.
Since the era of the
Romantics, various writers
have found this aspect of
music to be a kind of catnip
for the literary imagination.
Thomas Mann, for one, described
this phenomenon as, quote,
"the spoken unspokenness
given to music alone."
Rilke wrote of music
as, quote, "the language
where languages end."
And so, let's clarify
some chronology.
Before Mayor O'Dwyer announced
a memorial that would never
arrive, before The
Diary of Anne Frank
had been translated
into any other language,
before the first book
of survivor testimony
had been published
in the United States,
before Alain Resnais' pioneering
documentary Night and Fog,
and long before Adorno's
often quoted statement
on the impossibility of
poetry after Auschwitz,
the composer, Arnold
Schoenberg, who
had spent the war years
in exile in Los Angeles,
wrote a seven minute cantata
called A Survivor from Warsaw.
It became one of the first
major works of commemorative art
in any medium.
We may think of sound as the
most slippery, evanescent,
ever-vanishing medium of all.
But in its way, as
these examples show,
sonic memory can prove more
durable than that of stone.
The connection between
music and memory
might seem, at first blush,
to be so numerous and varied
as to elude our grasp.
The character, Swann, in
proofs from remembrance
of things past, is greeted with
a flood of personal memories
linked to a little
phrase in a violin sonata
by the fictional
composer Vinteuil.
And similarly, most listeners
can attest in their own lives
to music's ability to
trigger personal reflections,
upwellings of what Bergson
called memoire involontaire,
involuntary memory.
In fact, this linkage has
proven to be so robust
that iPods with
personalized playlists
are now increasingly being used
in the treatment for patients
with Alzheimer's and dementia,
as a way of excavating troves
of personal memories
that have otherwise
slipped beyond recall.
The role of concert music as a
medium of civic commemoration
may be equally accepted
on an intuitive level.
Only four months after the
attack of September 11,
the New York
Philharmonic contacted
the American composer,
John Adams, to commission
a memorial work, the
commission that became Adams'
On the Transmigration of Souls.
It was subsequently
premiered on the one year
anniversary of the attacks.
In his memoirs, Adams
describes reacting
to the request with hesitation,
given the enormity of the task,
but also with the
full understanding
of music's critical role in
this manner, historically,
and in the present.
Someone, he realized,
needed to write this work.
And yet, despite our
widely held notions
of these supposedly natural
linkages between music
and memory, music
and commemoration,
the subject has received
surprisingly little attention
from scholars.
Indeed, despite its status
as a pioneering exemplar
of the genre, you
won't find A Survivor
from Warsaw even mentioned
in many histories
of post-war memory.
And across a wide range of
scholarship in this area,
examining Holocaust
memory through the prism
of literature, film,
architectural monuments,
even pop culture,
one scarcely finds
concert music mentioned at all.
In our time today, I'd like to
pose a set of questions that
has informed my project
this year at the Radcliffe
institute, and I'd like
to at least gesture
in the direction of some
preliminary answers.
I'd also like to share with
you some musical examples.
And along the way, I
will try to be addressing
a series of questions--
What is lost when we
fail to consider sound
as a carrier of
meaning about the past?
Why is music, in
fact, particularly
effective as a medium
of cultural memory,
capable of powerfully
conveying personal and national
narratives about war,
rupture, and displacement?
How do monuments in sound
do their work differently
from their sibling
monuments in stone?
And on an experiential,
sensorial level,
how do oral and visual
encounters with memory art
differ from each other,
that is, memory perceived
through our ears
versus that which
is perceived through our eyes?
How, in short, has a wartime
past been inscribed in sound?
And what does it
mean to cultivate
new ways of hearing
these works precisely
at our current moment, that
is, as the generation that
lived through the reality
to which this music bears
testament is itself
fading into history?
So those are some questions to
keep in the back of our minds
as we proceed.
We may explore a few offshoots
and alleyways along the way.
But that's OK as well.
As a friend of
mine likes to say,
digression is the
sunshine of narrative.
[LAUGHTER]
Arnold Schoenberg was born
into a Viennese Jewish family
in 1874.
He is, of course, both revered
and reviled to this day
for his place as a forefather
of musical modernism,
the composer, who, in his
words, emancipated dissonance,
and, in so doing,
severed music's link
with the system of
tonal organization
that had governed the art
form since the Baroque era.
And yet, years before his
invention of his signature
twelve-tone method of
composition in 1921,
Schoenberg had staked out
his own radical position
on a subject perhaps even more
fundamental to music than its
harmonic language--
the ethical purpose of music.
The art of the future,
he felt strongly,
should not strive
to be beautiful.
It should strive to be true.
"Art," he wrote in
1911, "is the cry
of distress uttered by those
who experience firsthand
the fate of mankind."
In the early 1930s, Schoenberg
was among the very first
German-speaking
artists to perceive
the urgency of the threat
facing European Jews.
He emigrated in 1933 and
settled in Los Angeles.
After the war, which claimed
the lives of several family
members, he composed his own
short, but explosive, cry
of distress, his Survivor
from Warsaw, on a commission
from the foundation of Serge
Koussevitzky, music director
of the Boston Symphony.
Koussevitzky was renowned for
championing the music of living
composers, and he
gave Schoenberg
enormous creative latitude as
to how the commission would
be fulfilled.
Interesting, nothing I ended
up finding in the archives
indicates that
Koussevitzky had any idea
that Schoenberg
planned to compose
a memorial to the Holocaust.
We can imagine his surprise upon
receiving this bracing score.
He was a conductor,
after all, who
had a very different vision
for the role of music
in the era of post-war
reconstruction.
He spelled out that
vision in a speech
to the first class of students
who returned to Tanglewood,
once it reopened after the war.
He told the students,
"In light of music,
the soul beholds the
good and the beautiful,
the heart awakens to faith in
man and in his better future.
If you deprive men of music--
just as they were deprived
of honor, dignity,
human rights, conscience,
faith, and freedom--
you will witness the
decline of the world
to a state of brutality
and barbarism.
Music alone can still
tame the beast in man--
it is our comfort and our hope."
This is, of course,
quite far removed
from any notion of music as
the soul's cry of distress.
And A Survivor from
Warsaw, one might say,
does not tame any beast, but it
rather depicts them in its art.
As we'll hear shortly,
the piece itself
is a narrated scene that takes
place in a concentration camp.
This work would not be
Koussevitzky's avenue
to moral and
aesthetic redemption.
It's in those terms that
I interpret Koussevitzky's
otherwise mysterious decision
to tacitly decline the chance
to give the work's world
premiere with the Boston
Symphony.
Almost all of his
other commissions
received the BSO's
red carpet treatment.
Not this one.
Instead, I think because
Survivor from Warsaw
was so far ahead of the
curve of public Holocaust
memory in this
country, the score
was pushed to what
were then the margins
of American musical life.
In what is surely one of
the strangest premieres
of a major work
in music history,
this piece was unveiled
in a university gymnasium
in Albuquerque, New
Mexico, in 1948,
with an Austrian conductor
named Kurt Frederick leading
an amateur chorus and
an amateur orchestra.
The performers included cowboys,
florists, assorted students,
and railroad engineers.
The narrator was the head
of the university chemistry
department.
Here is a copy of the program.
The national press
sent correspondence.
The New York Times
ran a headline--
"Schoenberg in Albuquerque"--
sounding more like the set up
for a joke about two
things that go together
about as well as, say, a
Sachertorte and a campfire.
But from all accounts,
the work seems
to have been an unqualified
success at its premiere.
The piece had to
be repeated twice.
Time magazine
reported that applause
thundered in the auditorium.
Schoenberg was
not healthy enough
to travel for the performance,
but Kurt Frederick, just
after midnight on the
night of the premiere,
dashed off this telegram to
Schoenberg in Los Angeles--
"Survivor from Warsaw
made tremendous impression
on the performers and audience.
Thank you for the
great honor of allowing
us to perform this work."
In its early years, the
piece earned champions
well beyond the good burghers
of Albuquerque, New Mexico,
including one listener who
championed it precisely
for the same reasons
that Koussevitzky
appears to have ignored it.
I'm speaking of the philosopher,
critic, and musical thinker,
Theodor Adorno, who wrote
that, "In Survivor, perhaps
for the first time,
culture and barbarism
were not shown as
naively opposing forces,
but rather wrenched
into the frame
of a single explosive
work of art."
in Adorno's reading,
the work's incorporation
of horror and suffering
was exactly what
provided its truth content.
Here is a fuller
quote from Adorno--
"The effect of the
Survivor from Warsaw
is no less powerful--
a companion piece
to Picasso's Guernica--
in which Schoenberg
made the impossible
possible, standing up
to the contemporary horror
in its most extreme form,
the murder of the Jews, in art.
If music is to escape from
the nullity that threatens it,
the very loss of
its raison d'etre,
then it can only hope to
do so if it accomplishes
what Schoenberg accomplished
in the Survivor from Warsaw,
that is, if it confronts the
utter negativity, the most
extreme, by which the
entire complexion of reality
is made manifest."
To put his comment
in anecdotal form,
I'll mention that, in a
different essay on Schoenberg,
Adorno recalls the
memorable story
about Picasso's famous
depiction of wartime slaughter.
Gestapo officers were
said to have, one day,
approached the great
painter near a photograph
of his Guernica.
"Did you do this?"
they asked him.
"No," the painter
replied, "you did."
Before playing A
Survivor from Warsaw,
for those of you who
might not know the piece,
here is a quick overview
of what you'll be hearing.
It lasts just seven minutes.
It's scored for narrator and
orchestra and male chorus.
After a brief
orchestral opening,
the narrator recites a
text written by Schoenberg
to be delivered in a hybrid
speech-song style known
as Sprechstimme.
This narrator, as we'll
hear, describes a scene
he has witnessed in a
concentration camp involving
the beating of prisoners and
their selection for the gas
chamber.
At the climax of his
story, the men's choir
enters singing Schoenberg's
own setting of the Hebrew
words of the Shema Yisrael
prayer, the central prayer
of Judaism.
And one the last word of caution
before we press play here
for our musical example.
Judgment of this
score's aesthetic merits
has been all over the
map over the years, which
is, in fact, a subject of an
entirely different lecture--
how we should
think about judging
these monuments in aesthetic
terms, or in other terms.
But the piece has been
heralded as, quote,
"the aesthetic and ethical
manifesto of our time,"
unquote.
That was from Luigi Nono.
And it's also been derided
as, quote, "Hollywood kitsch."
You can each judge
for yourself, though
to the extent that
this is possible,
I'd ask you to listen in a
spirit of oral generosity,
and to remember, just as
historians like to caution us
against back-shadowing,
which is viewing
the past through the
prism of the present,
I think we'd be wise to
guard against the equivalent
phenomenon in the domains
of memory and listening.
In other words,
try to keep in mind
that this was written in
1947, before, as we've said,
just about any other artifact
of Holocaust you might think of.
If you'd like, you
can picture yourself
sitting in the Carlisle
Gymnasium of the University
of Albuquerque on November
4, 1948, the night
that this music
was actually new.
I'll put the text up here
for us to follow as we read.
And here is the piece that
they heard that night.
[MUSIC - ARNOLD SCHOENBERG, "A
SURVIVOR FROM WARSAW"]
- I cannot remember everything.
I must have been unconscious
most of the time.
I remember only the
grandiose moment
when they all started to
sing, as if prearranged
the old prayer
they had neglected
for so many years,
the forgotten creed.
But I have no recollection
how I got underground
to live in the sewers of
Warsaw so long a time.
The day began as usual--
Reveille when it still was dark.
"Get out!"
Whether you slept,
or whether worries
kept you awake the whole night.
You had been separated from
your children, from your wife,
from your parents.
You don't know what
happened to them.
How could you sleep?
The trumpets again--
"Get out!
The sergeant will be furious!"
They came out, some very
slowly-- the old ones,
the sick ones, some
with nervous agility.
They fear the sergeant.
They hurry as much as they can.
In vain!
Much too much noise,
much too much commotion!
And not fast enough!
The Feldwebel shouts--
"Achtung!
Stilljestanden!
Na wird's mal!
Oder soll ich mit dem
Jewehrkolben nachhelfen?
Na jut-- wenn ihrs
durchaus haben wollt!"
The sergeant and
his subordinates
hit everyone-- young
or old, strong or sick,
guilty or innocent.
It was painful to hear
them groaning and moaning.
I heard it though I had
been hit very hard, so hard
that I couldn't
help falling down.
We all on the ground
who couldn't stand up
were then beaten over the head.
I must have been unconscious.
The next thing I knew
was a soldier saying--
"They are all dead!"
Whereupon the sergeant ordered
leave to do away with us.
There I lay aside
half conscious.
It had become very still.
Fear and pain.
Then I heard the
sergeant shouting--
"Achtung!"
They started slowly
and irregularly--
one, two, three, four.
"Achtung!"
the sergeant shouted again.
"Rascher!
Nochmals von vorn anfange!
In einer Minute will ich wissen,
wieviele ich zur Gaskammer
abliefere!
Abzahlen!"
They began again, first slowly--
one, two, three, four.
Became faster and
faster, so fast
that they finally sounded like
a stampede of wild horses.
And all of a sudden,
in the middle of it,
they began singing
the Shema Yisrael.
[MEN'S CHOIR IN
BACKGROUND SINGING
"SHEMA YISRAEL"]
- Philosophers of
music have written
about an intriguing
enigma at the heart
of the work of music, a kind
of ontological fuzziness.
In the case of painting,
once the artist
has finished her
creative activity,
the painted canvas itself is
manifestly the work of art.
But where, or alternatively,
when does the work of musical
art reside?
Is a score like this
one-- or let's say,
is Beethoven's Ninth Symphony--
is the piece itself to be found
in the score of Beethoven's
Ninth?
Is it located in a particular
performance of the symphony?
In the average of many
performances over time?
Or perhaps in some platonic
idealized version of the score
that lives only in our minds?
In short, a kind of
temporal ambiguity
appears to be part of the
notated music tradition itself.
A score is a blueprint--
instructions for
realization at a later date.
We might go further
still to suggest
that the active musical
performance of any score
exposes listeners to a unique
kind of enlarged temporality,
a bridge between the present
tense of the listener
experiencing the performance and
the present tense of the music
at the time of its composition.
In this sense, we might say
that a musical monument carries
in it a memory of
its own history,
and a performance of a
musical memorial as such--
a work like the
one we just heard,
whose subject is
itself commemorative--
can make for a doubly
strong bridge to the past.
So that sense of
enlarged temporality
is one special
attribute of music
I've been trying to get
my mind around this year.
But let's also quickly
mention a second attribute,
a certain visceral quality that
I think we would all probably
agree comes through very clearly
in the example we just heard.
It's an immediacy that seems
to attend to sound as such.
It seems connected,
I would think,
to the nature of hearing.
The composer Murray
Schafer has written,
"The eye points outward,
the ear points inward."
Schafer, who first popularized
the notion of the soundscape,
which I use in my
title, also reminds us
that, when we fall
asleep at night,
it is our hearing that is
the last of the five senses
to relinquish its guard.
And it's the first one
to return in the morning.
In brief, in my
recent work, I've
been aiming to develop
ways to write and think
about musical memory that
do justice to these sui
generis properties
of sound itself,
and of music as an art form.
I believe that we can't simply
import wholesale an approach
from the domains of art
history or visual studies.
Musical memorials,
I'm arguing here,
offer the possibility of
a unique, and perhaps more
immersive, grappling with
the performance of memory
then and now.
Adapting from Bakhtin, we can
say they have a special way of,
quote, "thickening time,
introducing new continuities."
Under the best conditions,
I am suggesting,
these works can help dispel
what Walter Benjamin described
as the expanse of homogeneous
empty time separating us
from the past.
Instead, musical memory,
works like this one,
have the potential to bring us
closer to what Benjamin called
the jetztzeit, or
in his words, "time
filled by the
presence of the now."
Speaking of time, in the stretch
that we have remaining together
today, I'd like to
speak about one more
score, another instance
of musical memory,
and then offer some
concluding thoughts.
In A Survivor from
Warsaw, we've already
heard a piece that
derives its power,
it's kind of burning
intensity, in part
from its composer's
proximity, I think,
to the history he describes.
There is a rawness
and a directness
to that piece of music.
I'd now like to turn to a
different score that speaks,
at a certain level, of
temporal and geographic removed
from the war years.
In that sense, it addresses
more seamlessly the moment
we are living in today.
The American composer, Steve
Reich, was born in 1936
and grew up in this country,
far from the agonies of Europe.
As a boy with divorced parents
living on opposite coasts,
he used to take long
train voyages, accompanied
by his governess, between
New York and Los Angeles.
Decades later, as an
adult, in the 1980s,
he came across the iconic photo
of a frightened boy standing
on the streets of the Warsaw
ghetto with his hands raised.
Reich saw in that boy an
image of a kind of alter self.
He and the boy looked
physically alike, he thought,
and given the year
of the photo, they
might well have been
born at the same time.
They were separated,
Reich realized,
only by a senseless
accident of fate.
Had he, Reich, been
born in Europe,
the trains he rode as
a child, he realized,
would not be associated
with quaint memories
of Pullman porters
and of his governess.
They would have been, in his
phrase, different trains.
This became the title,
and the framing conceit,
of Reich's three movement work
for string quartet and tape
that was premiered in 1988.
Some of you have surely
heard it performed.
We'll hear a little bit
of the music in a moment.
The defining gesture of
Reich's musical score
is the transfer of
actual survivor voices,
present through samples that
he took from recorded survivor
testimony, into the voices of
the instruments of the string
quartet, which played
lines transcribed
from the contours
of the spoken words.
Memory here is, quite
literally, inscribed in sound.
It may seem as abstract
as I describe it now,
but we'll see and hear shortly
the technique is actually
beautifully simple
and, in a way,
this work embodies another set
of themes I've tried to weave
through this afternoon's talk.
Different Trains is
music that dances
in that liminal space between
spoken and the unspoken,
between the flinty
precision of language
and the watery
sensuality of sound.
Throughout this piece,
there is no narrator, only
shards of disconnected speech--
tiny slivers of language
that, with a kind
of metonymic virtuosity,
become all that
is required at this
late date to summon
the enormity of the tragedy.
In this brief
excerpt, we'll hear
a survivor named Rachella say
a few simple words and phrases.
"1940," she says.
Then later, "on my birthday."
Then later again, "the
Germans walked in."
We will hear a
viola, or at times,
a cello tracing the rise and
fall of Rachella's voice,
and then picking up the
resulting melodic line
shorn of its words.
We'll also, I will warn you,
hear Reich's use of sirens.
Let's have a listen.
Here is the first two minutes
of the second movement
of Different Trains.
[MUSIC - STEVE REICH, "DIFFERENT
TRAINS"]
- 1940.
1940.
On my birthday.
The Germans walked in.
Walked into Holland.
- Germans invaded Hungary.
I was in second grade.
I had a teacher.
I had a teacher,
a very tall man,
his hair was completely
plastered smooth.
A very tall man, his hair was
completely plastered smooth.
A very tall man.
He said, "Black Crows"--
"Black Crows"-- He said, "Black
Crows invaded our country."
He said, "Black Crows invaded
our country many years ago."
And he pointed right at me.
He pointed right at me.
- That was just a
snippet, of course,
and please believe me, the
work's full power comes through
much more clearly
as an entirety,
preferably in a
live performance.
This was enough, though,
I hope, to give you
a sense of the ways in
which the score actually
furnishes more than just a
potent listening experience.
It also operationalizes,
if we could say,
a certain store of metaphors.
By inviting the listener to
reverse engineer his melodies,
to associate them with the
actual voices that formed
their contours, the
voices from the era,
Reich makes
overwhelmingly tactile
the ways in which the
past is always conferring
its shape on the present.
And then, like the
voices, taking its leave.
At the same time,
this piece wants
to hold on to the
singularity of those voices,
those links to actual people.
I think it is this
documentary specificity that
helps this score to
avoid the pitfalls of so
much other memorial art.
And I'm speaking of the
cinematic re-enactments
and memory kitsch that I think
can feel pervasive these days,
and can sometimes threaten
to numb the senses.
Reich's Different
Trains ultimately
makes palpable the
ways in which the past
we are discussing tonight
oscillates between the spoken
and the unspoken.
It also, I think, resonates
with our contemporary moment,
when the actual living memory
of the Holocaust is receding,
and the generation who
experienced it directly
continues to fade.
Like Reich's sampled
voices, their memories
now leave cultural traces that,
in turn, shape the contours
and cadences of our own.
By way of a conclusion, I'd
like to refresh our memories
about the well-known closing
passage of Adorno's Minima
Moralia, a book
composed of fragments.
In this passage,
as I see it, Adorno
came close to
distilling his life's
work in a single sentence.
He wrote that,
quote, "Perspectives
must be fashioned that displace
and estrange the world,
reveal it to be, with
its rifts and crevices,
as indigent and distorted
as it will one day appear
in the messianic light."
For Adorno, this, and this
alone, was the task of thought,
and certainly the task
of critical theory.
Yet, I believe
Adorno, of all people,
would forgive us one further
interpolation, that he would,
in fact, agree that this
self-same mission is also one
of the essential
tasks of art itself--
to fashion the
perspectives on the world,
from which the brokenness--
the rifts and fissures--
of the present and the
past are revealed and felt
for what they are.
And not only the brokenness
in the past, of course,
but also its buried sparks
of hope for a future
that might still have
turned out differently.
Every modern art
form contributes
to this task in different ways.
As I hope I've given you at
least a glimpse of today,
music has its own
contribution to make.
For me, at least, it has always
been the best of the arts
at conveying this expanded
present tense, that sense
of contact with
history and memory,
and that basic truth so
elegantly distilled by WG
Sebald in a deceptively
simple observation.
He wrote that, quote, "Time
measures nothing but itself."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm a professor emeritus of
English, of Nichols College,
and, yes, I've just
been reading a lot
of Baudelaire's critiques.
And I noticed that both of the
pieces that you played to us
have words with them.
And the Guernica did not have
words associated with it,
but it was not realism.
So the imagination
of the listener
could be set free to imagine.
And I was wondering
what you think
about composers like Schoenberg
adding words to his music,
so that somehow that defines
the memory that you're
going to have, rather
than opening up
the listener's memory to
his or her own thoughts?
- Yeah, absolutely.
It's a great point.
We spoke about all
those semantic tricks
that abstract music
can play, and then I
went ahead and played you
two excerpts with words.
The short answer is
that I think there
are really effective
musical memorials in both
of those types, both
of those genres.
In the book project
that I'm working on,
I hope to spend some
time writing and thinking
about Strauss'
Metamorphosen, which
is a strictly instrumental
work that was written shortly
after the war, and is heard
by many as a kind of memorial
to the destruction
of German culture.
And I think that what I tried
to bring out also in the Reich
was that the words--
I don't personally feel actually
that the words in the Reich
really guide us into any
particular narrative,
because they don't
actually tell the story.
But what they do do,
as I was trying to say,
was that they anchor the piece
in the actual documentary
details, the actual
voices of the people
who lived through that
era, and, at the same time,
abstract from them
with the musical lines
that he derives
from their voices.
And so I think,
in that way, it's
a perfect memorial for this
particular moment, when
we are right there on the
threshold between what
sometimes gets called
communicative memory,
or talking, telling stories,
and cultural memory,
preserved through
art and other things.
Yeah?
- Hi.
My name's Julie [INAUDIBLE],
and your discussion
of Different Trains
threw me back
into my own musical memory.
I was at the performance that
the Kronos Quartet did here
in Cambridge when they
were first touring it.
I was in my late 20s.
I was a composition student,
with a group of friends,
who were not
professional musicians,
but we all went and did lots of
cool cultural stuff together.
And all of my
friends were Jewish.
And two of them-- although I
didn't know it at the time--
were children of survivors.
We didn't know what
was on the program,
and so this piece came as
a surprise to everyone.
Being a composer, I was
very focused on what
he was doing with the
tape and the rhythm,
and all that kind of stuff.
And we had, I think, one
of the longest and most
passionate discussions after
this concert among my friends
I experienced with that group.
And looking back,
my two friends,
whose parents had
survived the camps,
were the ones who were most
angry about this piece.
They found it utterly insulting.
They found it trivializing,
and they hated
the fragmentation of the text.
And just now, it
was making me wonder
about the space between
memorializing and experiencing.
And I wondered if you might
say a little about that?
- It's a great question,
and that's a big subject,
of course.
I quoted from Adorno's very
affirmative embrace of Survivor
from Warsaw as a
piece that reflected
and incorporated the
barbarism of the times
into the frame of the artwork,
like Picasso's Guernica.
What I didn't quote from is
some of the later opinions
he had of the work.
He was around for long enough
after the war to reconsider his
opinions, and wrote, really
interestingly, in the 1960s,
a kind of second thoughts
on Survivor from Warsaw,
and spoke in particular about
a certain operea, he called it,
that exists in Survivor from
Warsaw between acknowledging
the victims of the
Holocaust-- the barbarism,
the violence that
was done to them--
on the one hand, but also being
careful not to instrumentalize
their memories, to use them
for the purpose of somehow
possibly entertaining an
audience, or giving them
pleasure.
Because of course, at
the end of the day,
this was a tragedy for which
there is no redemption.
There was only death.
And so this question
he raises of--
he says something
along the lines
that, no work of art that
ignores the victims can
possibly be of credit, or
of value, in this context,
and at the same time, no work
of art that that exploits
their memories should be
allowed to stand as well.
So for him, that was the operea
in which all memory art stands.
And I do think of that as
a kind of guiding framework
for thinking about all of
our writing and responses
and engagement with these works.
I think that, for
different people,
they will draw that
line differently,
and even the line perhaps seems
different at different points
of remove from when
the work was written,
and as we ourselves
change and grow older.
I would wonder what
your friends might feel
about Different Trains now.
But I think those are
some very good points.
Thank you for your comment.
- I'm Dan Wikler.
I'm a professor at the
School of Public Health,
and I have a brief observation,
and then a question.
Many years ago, I read
Perfect Pitch, a memoir
by a musical lexicographer,
Nicholas Slonimsky.
And I believe he said
in there, at one point,
he had been close
to Koussevitzky,
who then suddenly turned on
him and sort of dismissed him.
And it hurt his
feelings terribly.
And if I remember right, his
wife, as she threw him out
of their living
room, said, you're
nothing but a cheap, Odessa Jew.
And Slonimsky's thought to
himself, as he walked away,
but Koussevitzky's
an Odessa Jew, too.
And I know that
Koussevitzky had converted
to Christianity, either as a
teenager or as a young man,
and was buried in a
Christian graveyard,
and I wonder if there's
some problems there
that might help to explain why
he didn't play the Schoenberg.
The question is this--
you mentioned Resnais'
movie, Night and Fog,
which I've seen more
times than I can count.
One striking thing about
that movie is the score.
It's by Hanns Eisler.
And when I first heard
the score, I thought,
this is wildly inappropriate.
It's not a dirge,
or it's not even--
It doesn't sound sad.
It's a kind of
almost perky score.
It's mood changes
from moment to moment.
But if I heard that
thing in a concert,
without being told that it
was written for Night and Fog,
I would never have dreamed it.
But over time, as I've watched
that film over and over,
and heard that music,
it's come, to me,
to seem the absolutely
perfect music for that movie.
And I almost can't imagine
the movie without it.
And I don't know whether
it's my brain making this up,
or whether there's
something in the music
that he somehow had figured out,
despite the fact that it seems
so completely different in tone.
And I wondered if you
have any thoughts on that?
- Yeah.
So Hanns Eisler, the
composer of that score,
was a student of
Arnold Schoenberg's.
After A Survivor from
Warsaw was written,
Eisler had comments
in a lecture,
or a published
article, in which he
said that Schoenberg was
the quintessential composer
of fear, and that his
genius was in the fact
that he understood the
meaning of aerial bombardment
and the meaning of
the gas chambers
back at a time when
the world was still
safe for the man in the street.
So Eisler, I think, had a very
apt sense, and sharp sense,
of what Schoenberg
was trying to do.
As
As for that film, I mean,
I think it's interesting
that familiarity
sometimes breeds contempt,
and also, of course, sometimes
love when it comes to music.
I thought also, during
your comment, about some
of the ideas Philip
Glass sometimes brings up
when he talks about
his own film music,
and the idea of a score's
purpose as not to necessarily
create an auditory analog,
a sonic kind of mirror,
to the action that you're
seeing in the film,
but rather to open
up a sense of space,
almost a sense of
distance, between the music
and the action within
which we, as viewers,
or the individual self, can
appreciate what's being offered
to maximum effect.
Obviously, Eisler had not
read Philip Glass when doing--
and Philip Glass had
written those things yet.
But those are a few thoughts
in responses to your comment.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Hello.
I'm Aleksandra Kremer.
I'm an assistant
professor of Polish
from the Slavic Department
here at Harvard.
And I have like a very
short commentary, which
will lead me to my question.
And so thank you
for your great talk.
Well, from the
American perspective,
and also from the
perspective of music,
certainly Schoenberg's work
is like a very early response,
very quick response.
It made me very quickly to think
also about earlier artistic
responses to
Holocaust, and to war,
which appeared especially
in Polish culture, like,
for example, Czeslaw Milosz,
who lived in the occupied Warsaw
exactly at the time of
the ghetto uprising,
and wrote two of his important
poems in '43 already--
A Poor Christian Looks at the
Ghetto and Campo dei Fiori.
I think also of Zofia Nalkowska,
whose book, Medallions,
responses to exactly
the Nazis crimes.
And I think of Tadeusz
Borowsky, translated as,
This Way for the Gas,
Ladies and Gentlemen.
This was '46 already.
And these were all
like radical revisions
of what literature can be.
And also, in terms
of memorialization,
like the first tablet
honoring the heroes
of the ghetto
uprising in Warsaw.
In Warsaw, it was '46,
and the monument's '48.
So it's like, from
European perspective,
it's not that
early, even in '47.
And this leads me
to a question--
to what extent, really,
the soundscape, which
you have in your title, are
best conveyed via music,
and not, for example,
like literature,
as the soundscape also
consists of so many words
and exclamations.
And also, when I think
about theater and cinema,
to what extent really
full soundscape can
be best preserved in
the work of musical art,
which is still not that radical,
in terms of experimentation,
at least what we have here.
And do you have any thoughts,
like a rivalry of these words,
literature and music, in
terms of memorialization,
because you mostly talked about
visual arts and monuments?
And I would like to
thank you so much.
- Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
And I would never like
to think about a rivalry
between literature and
music, as regards memory art.
And I would hope that we
wouldn't have to choose.
It does seem like, in
my own work with some
of these pieces, and
generally as a critic,
I've often tried to read
music and literature, or music
and other arts, in the
image of each other,
as a helpful way to write and
to think, and to make sense
of what was being done by these
artists who were all breathing
the same air.
The idea of the
soundscape in the title,
again, comes from
Murray Schafer.
And I hadn't been
thinking about it
as kind of having anyone
appointed to sort of check
the passport of the art form at
the border, if you understand.
I would be happy to think
more about literature's place
in the soundscape.
For me, it was just
a way of distilling
this idea of auditory
memory, and of getting
at some of these issues
of sound specificity.
I have in my work already
written a whole chapter
on the way stone monuments
differ from monuments in sound.
And it's a great
idea, perhaps it
would be really helpful and
instructive, to think through,
in a systematic
way, how memorials
in literature and
words also might
differ from memorials in sound.
Thank you for your comment.
- My name is Donald Tipper.
I'm a retired professor
at the University
of Massachusetts Medical School.
And I had a question
relating to a somewhat more
universal consequence
of warfare,
and that is the
effect on children.
That happens wherever
it is, whatever
country, the young always
those who suffer terribly.
I was four years old
when war was declared
in the United Kingdom
in 1939, and I
can remember it very well.
But there are certain things
that bring back memories.
Of course, odors are the most
direct things that bring back
memories to almost everybody.
But sound is probably next.
And for a child who lived in a
country which was not invaded,
but which was bombarded, the
sound that is most provocative
is the sound of the
air raid warning sound.
Just a siren going up and down.
That was actually
part of the background
music in the Koussevitzky,
I think it was.
And I'm surprised that there
are not more references
to that kind of
influence of sound
within the music
that tries to reflect
the experiences of warfare.
Of course, explosions
and that sort of thing,
everybody can expect that.
But something that has more to
do with everybody's experience.
Because not
everybody is directly
affected by such events,
but the fear is universal.
I don't know what you
can say about that,
but I just thought it
was worth discussing.
- Thank you for
your observation.
There were so many
musical memorials
I didn't get to speak
about today because we
had a short amount of time.
One of them, of course,
is Britten's War Requiem,
which was written in
response to the 1940
bombing of the Coventry
Cathedral in the UK.
And incidentally, the Nazi code
name for that bombing operation
was Moonlight Sonata.
There are other memorials,
not necessarily the Britten,
but other ones.
For example, there's a piece
written, called Threnody
for the Victims of Hiroshima.
There are all kinds
of memorials that
do try to take a more
naturalistic approach
to depicting what is the actual
auditory landscape, soundscape
of war.
You know, samples
and other things.
I think it gets us back
into some thorny territory.
Is that kind of
direct literalness,
if you will-- transcribing
the wartime acoustic-- is
that going to be the
most effective medium
of commemoration?
Or is there something
reductive in that,
and will some people find more
powerful these other works that
are trying, in different
kinds of evocative language
and with texts, to maybe
get to a similar place?
But it's a really good point.
And it reminds me
to emphasize to you
all just how we've got to hear
obviously a very small range
of musical memorials today.
- I'm Daniel Stepner.
I'm a musician.
So many references came up.
So many things.
Just to mention a few,
[INAUDIBLE] seems to me
a memorial of European culture
before the First World War.
Very interesting.
Also, Charles Ives'
song, They Are There.
There's a recording you can find
online, I'm sure, now of Ives
himself singing this,
and playing piano
while he's singing, and it is
full of such incredible energy
and rage at Hitler, basically.
It was recorded during the
war, but it's worth hearing,
I think.
An important document.
But I guess my question,
Jeremy, is based on a lecture
I heard you do last year
at Brandeis, and that is,
linking Survivor from Warsaw
to Schoenberg's opera, Moses
and Aaron, do you care to
talk about that a little bit?
- Sure.
That's great.
Thank you.
So I have written--
it's strange to say, but
I have written a full page
manuscript about those seven
minutes of music that we heard.
And one aspect of what Mr.
Stepner is referring to
is that I spend a
lot of time talking
about Schoenberg's opera,
Moses and Aaron, which
was the last major work he
completed while still living
in Germany, before fleeing
to the United States.
It's a biblically-themed opera.
It has two acts
that were written,
and a third that
was never completed.
There is a lot to
say about that,
and we're basically out
of time, so I'm just
going to try to distill
a kernel or two.
I think it was Schoenberg's
daughter, Nuria,
who first referenced in passing
this idea that perhaps Survivor
from Warsaw should be thought
of as the third act of Moses
and Aaron.
And this is, I found, a very
provocative and suggestive line
of thinking, And
one that I ended up
picking up in that longer
work and drawing out
a lot of these connections.
I think that the reason that
Schoenberg could not complete
Moses and Aaron-- and this
is my own personal theory--
is that the work itself was
this kind of final Herculean
attempt to hold in tension,
and really to reconcile,
these forces of
Jewishness and Germanness
that were so definitive for him
over the course of his life up
to that point.
And of course, when he tried
to return to the work in exile,
the very idea of that
reconciliation of Germanness
and Jewishness had itself
been sort of, we can say,
I guess, shipwrecked by history.
So there's a lot of connection
between Moses and Aaron
and Survivor, and it would be
fun to talk about that with you
all some other time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]